[Music]  it's et social study a look at what the  stars are posting online hayden  Panettiere doing some mommy  troubleshooting on an airplane after her  daughter peed on the floor of the  bathroom pregnant Beyonce shared new  pics as she rocked this sexy mini dress  and thigh-high boots ensemble to her  stepfather Richard Lawson's 70th  birthday party Emily Ratajkowski hit the  streets of New York City in sexy  lingerie morning the Occident the new  video is part of an ad campaign for DKNY  Nick Cannon is already back on the grind  after it was announced tyra banks will  replace him as host on America's Got  Talent he shared a new pic from inside  the studio and the star-studded wrinkle  in time movie has wrapped filming  director Ava Duvernay Mindy Kaling and  Reese Witherspoon shared farewell photos  from set  [Music]  you